[Musique]
exactement
raël à 14 ans et découvre son travail
exposé sur les murs d'une galerie d'art
réputé à besançon le résultat d'une
complicité avec cette jeune artiste
professionnel qui vient de passer
plusieurs mois avec les jeunes résidents
des eaux de bregille une dizaine
d'adolescents polyhandicapée dont
s'occupe quotidiennement l'institution
c'est comment permettent aussi à ces
jeunes et à ses enfants mais à travers
la culture de d'exister aussi est de
montrer ce qu'ils sont capables de faire
face qu'ils ont beaucoup de choses à me
montrer un travail qui avait commencé au
début de l'année
rassemblant toute l'énergie des
éducateurs autour d'un atelier
entièrement dédié à un grand projet
artistique je sais pas s'ils ont tout à
fait tu avais conscience de ce que de ce
que ça va de ce que ça va être
oui vive le le jour maintenant tout de
suite comme ça et il le vit rien qu'ils
arrivent à laisser quelque chose qui
n'est et qu'ils sachent que inexistante
en quelque sorte qu'ils ont leur propre
leurs propres actions sur le monde qui
les entoure et qu' ils sont quelques uns
dans ce monde là une volonté de toute
l'équipe pédagogique d'associer
l'ensemble des disciplines paramédical
afin de créer les meilleures conditions
de travail avec les jeunes
par exemple dire m ben elle peut bouger
ses bras mais oui il ya des mouvements
en fait avec les muses qui sont toujours
très tendue donc du coup bah moi voilà
je vais up l'aider comme ça à pouvoir
tenir le crayon et après en fait je la
laisse faire
donc c'est juste un soutien pour que les
jeunes voilà ils puissent exprimer au
mieux ce qui s'affaire une aventure
devenu même pour certains la possibilité
pourquoi pas d'une vocation
devenir un artiste tu es un artiste
le rêve de lianes qui s'est finalement
réalisé ce mois de juin où ses oeuvres
ont pris la direction de cette galerie
d'art à besançon comme pour l'ensemble
des travaux des jeunes résidentes des
salins de bregille le grand jour pour
toute l'équipe pédagogique et les
familles invités au vernissage d'une
exposition
[Musique]
non savais pas trop à quoi s'attendre
comme ça
mais il a sacré boulot et un sacré
boulot
bien travaillé l'artiste il m'a dit
l'artiste et moi des artistes et des
oeuvres défendue par le galeriste en
personne je trouvais que c'était
effectivement important de mettre en
valeur leur travail dans une vraie
galerie
oui ces deux là sont des artistes
tél
débat